viven los anteriores que habiamos visto
cómo pasar por la fórmula fórmula ecuestre
empirika la composición inacción composición
quien nace
podemos sin arrepentirnos con la fórmula es típica
actitud que en este caso es idéntica a la
fórmula de la molécula en los niveles anteriores
solo tenemos ese porcentaje de agua y
oxígeno y qué porcentaje rs trofeo no a
lamentable manera simas era asi en la masa
de oxigeno
estas seis unidades de masa atómica a
amenaza de libro delgado e hizo un balance de
toda la molécula estas bases hay masa
hidrógeno atómico que me uno pero estos
seis por un oxigeno
estos equivalen a siete años
la composición del oxígeno ss6 entre 7 y 6
1 e igualó 88 punto 9 por ciento
Crecí gen de agua por la oreja que tenemos si
podemos hacerlo de otra manera
Quiero ver si podemos pedir prestado con el
la composición de la lanza requiere el porcentaje
de la composición de los diferentes elementos en
una molécula y con eso cambiará la forma
fórmula empírica empírica para ser la
al contrario de lo que habíamos hecho antes
pagamos algunos ejercicios para ver eso
podemos jugar no sabemos tenemos una voz
de la cocina de sustancia y tono de 75 por
por ciento por qué elegancia y mercurio
mezclar
y él otro 25% explorador
si me preguntara cual es la formula
su empírica lo que tiene aquí supone ir
queso en su fórmula empírica molécula
para abordar este problema
supongamos que tenemos 100 gramos de todos
esto y por qué lo que se pone en el por qué es
más fácil de asumir juntos sí grande
si tenemos 100 gramos a cuantos
gramos y mercurio tenemos este medio
que tenemos el 75% y tt s
setenta y cinco gramos de mercurio y
también significa que son 25 gramos menos
y por supuesto estos números su hermana por
cien y eso es un problema para nosotros, pero uno de los
porcentajes en un 5%
estamos uniendo que hemos llegado el a
sustancia podría haber elegido otra
número de piedras grandes por mes 100
gramos es más fácil porque el
porcentajes de spam como telegram
Ya pregunté cuantas salsas y mercurio la
en 75 grande
necesitamos convertir para grabar el
ama
juzgamos de otra manera el mon de
mercurio requieren seis puntos generados por
esto plantea en el que tres átomos y mercurio
y si es igual a ellos en el texto de masa poner
estos son iguales a la masa atómica del mercurio
buscamos la masa molecular del mercurio
y la tabla periódica y el mercurio en
el mercurio forma parte de los metales y
transiciones y unirse a los pocos que
esta en estado liquido
a 25°C desde que la conquista de Mercurio de su
masa molecular y z 200 puntos 59
vamos a salir de ahi a las 200 en transito
mercurio urbano es igual a 200 grandes
y como sup porque el mercurio tenía un
masa de 200 unidades de masa atómica y
tanques
el nombre de mercurio requiere seis puntos
ser utilizado por israel 23 átomos y
mercurio en esta cantidad de granos
entonces en lugar de tener 200 unidades
de masa por átomo
tenemos 200 gramos por matanza excepto 200
gramos por muchos cálculos el
fuegos solo tenemos que saber cuales en el
masa tomita y esa mancha que
corresponde al noreste la sustancia se une
la roca tendrá mucho cloro
creemos que es el mismo procedimiento vamos
saber
ganamos en la tabla periodica
declaró que está en nuestro atómico de 35
punto 40 y si de genocidio en 35 y tambien
ser pieza de átomos de cloro
el hijo mas ambiente y valdecir en esto
de 35 unidades de masa atómica seis
puntadas correctas durante días y tomar tres
átomos de cloro
también podemos ir a un molecular o
Tengo en la masa de 35 tan grande como el
salsas de mercurio tenemos sonido 75 gramos
de mercurio y sabemos que un nombre de
el mercurio tiene una masa de 200 gramos
simplemente emitimos 75 entre profesores
calculadora emos 75 entre 200 y si
es igual
punto 375 estos son iguales punto 3 175
con salsas y mercurio y como youtube
con una regla de tres
si el nombre de mercurio es igual a 200
gramos y en los otros tenemos 75 gramos y
mercurio 75 por un año entre 250 la perra
375 recuerda que si quisieras hacer esto
el numero de atomos
hay que multiplicar en las salsas sin embargo
número de abogados y si por seis puntos
ser utilizado por este durante 23 años el número
de átomos que tenemos es el tiempo para los racimos de
flor
tenemos 25 gramos de cloro y 19 gramos de cloro y
si es igual a 35 gramos
entonces tenemos 25 de 35
esto es 25 de 35
estas como perra 714 salsas de calor
toma este numero y una x de los numeros
Exactamente este existió este de aquí
también hay un doble de acción para este pavo
aproximadamente el doble de cloro
tenemos y mercurio y este mes y ese
por lo tanto, la ingesta récord de mercurio en el
paquetes de sonidos o un número para cada átomo
mercurio de los átomos de cloro
por lo que la fórmula empírica es por lo tanto
al alcance del mercurio
ay del peor selecto que los numeros no
son exactamente los textos que esta en
acercamiento a mujer cam en realidad
por cada átomo de mercurio
sector aitor este numero es si w at
que tenemos molise mercurio y esto apunta
75 pedro esto es bastante rodeo lo
tenemos
mercurio explotado pagamos otro
ejercicio como este
supongamos que tenemos algo más entonces
9% se mueve esmarn y el resto requiere 91
por ciento este año y el camino a
absorber el islam que es otro
ejemplo
supongamos que hemos maldecido todo
sustancia
por qué no recordamos el magnesio
y 91 gramos vehículo
ahora tenemos que saber cuanto cuesta
nombre de la gerencia y la otra noche
el monje de magnesio el nombre de magnesio y el
salsa de kioto
sepamos y en la tabla periodica en
West 24 masa de magnesio en marcha
que el regalo que esta del otro lado
existente 27
jugó formar parte de los estudiantes en
demasiado tráfico urbano este año y si
salve las 24 trans y mucho de eso yo
soy igual a 27
entonces ella tomó de lo que tengo puesto
masa de 127 unidades de masa atómica
porque un hotel tiene gramófono y si
es igual a mentes rojas y tucanes para esto
pero ya tenemos la noche y el techo y con un
modelo más nicho para y tomó tu nombre
es igual a a24 grande
Ahora podemos calcular cuántos racimos de
esto es lo que tenemos
no es verano los otros en este reflejo
las mujeres mueren
hay cuatro grandes así que si estos
igual a nieve entre 24 no se ve entre
24 molise maniche neve entre 24 y si
igual al niño 3 75 que es muy similar
a que problema del turismo senior
anterior
mientras tanto por 91 gramos de kyoto
bueno do iguaçu a 127 granos en trance
esto es 91 de 127 primavera 91 de entre
me siento 27 t
estos igual a puntos y 306 puntos 700 y
que en la misma proporción porque el problema
anterior
aproximadamente un punto 72 racimos de
kyoto y esto es demasiado suave en este como en el
problema anterior
ahora tenemos aproximadamente así que toma
átomos y kyoto
los átomos de magnesio clave para cada clase
de otro misil
ai aproximadamente los átomos de todo
noche excepto pavo es bastante aceptado
el tic la formula ipca este principio de
otro de los equipos sigue hasta el mas
necesitados y cuatro derrotas
esto lo sabemos por lo que sabemos es que
la proporción de magnesio en los unoatos
siguiente tenía que tratar de buscar
otros ejercicios con proporciones más altas
interesante porque no quiero a todos
los ejercicios y parís por la esperanza de que
esto y va asi tutti